i mean it is hard to believe that only
two acts to get to move on after tonight
that's unbelievable it's unbelievable my
uh the stylist is telling me to
straighten the jacket straight
you look sharp as always i know i did
but there's always somebody standing
behind the camera going
i don't know what it is but apparently
can you imagine i mean having somebody
on the other side of the camera
constantly wherever you go you end up at
a rest you're shopping you're in the in
the produce session and there's the
produce produce section and there's
somebody at the end of aisle six can i
tell you something the cart make the car
that's a dream howie that's a dream okay
yes really yeah how am i looking
further ahead move the avocados to the
left
i mean honestly tonight how glad are you
that it's up to america and not you oh
my god it is incredible pressure and as
much as i'm glad it's them i'm also
upset that we have given the control
away i don't know what i would do and i
can't give you an answer of who the top
two and it's always speaking of produce
apples and oranges i mean how do you
compare one with the other talent is
subjective but you have to admit anybody
who watched any part of this has to
admit that so many people just went
above and beyond whatever the
expectation would have been i mean
between dustin last week and chapel
heart this week i mean could we have two
country acts in the finals this year
nearly two country acts do you realize
that we are putting out this year more
than i would imagine more than any other
show at this point
we've uh dropped
i think this is going to be our third
and fourth number one hit on itunes yeah
on itunes come on yes i mean agt only
produces hit makers okay yeah that's
what we do that's what we do that's what
we do you show up here
you're on the charts
that's it speak it up let's talk about
maddie or golden buzzer how did she do
today because obviously her audition was
a lot different than what the live
performance we got mission was a
surprise
[Music]
[Applause]
and i think she was surprised at the
fact i mean terry and the producers put
her in the audience but nobody could
plan because they didn't tell us how
we'd how we would react the fact that we
would bring her live on the stage it
would be a great moment for the show but
that could have been a great moment in
the audience she was brought to the
stage and then ended up with a golden
buzzer and then showing up tonight and
doing even more and uh i was talking to
somebody earlier when i went up on stage
i went where's your dad she was just
sitting there she was standing there in
tears and she said her dad is not
feeling well tonight he couldn't even
make it tonight
no
and that's a big deal for him not to be
here you know that she talked about if
you watch the package that she's
inspired to sing because that
brought her dad through
cancer and i don't know what the issue
is tonight but the fact that he can't be
here for a 12 year old little girl is a
big deal so with on top of the pressure
of competing on top of the pressure of
it being live she's dealing with that so
you know my prayers and heart and
hopes are with maddie right now i think
you're the youngest contestant this
season but you are a pro already
all right
good luck tonight maddie do you think
that's where those tears were coming
from at the end of her performance
tonight yes and more you know the end of
her performance what this means to her
the fact that uh you know you put you as
a performer you know you just put your
heart and soul into it these are
people's hopes and dreams this is what
she wants for a life this is a
fairy tale
[Music]